pont de grenelle déboulonnage provisoire
de la statue de la liberté afin de
permettre la construction d'un nouveau
pont le délicat transport fut mené avec
beaucoup d'égards envers cette grande
dame qui servit de modèle à la statue de
new york
monsieur cost combien de temps cette
statue va rester en quarantaine
ce statut va rester sur cette aire
provisoire pendant la durée de
reconstruction du pont de grenelle c'est
à dire pendant deux ans environ
mais n'y at il pas quelques danger
lorsque transports c'est une opération
qui est assez délicate surtout au départ
au moment où la statue soulève de son
soc
y at il eu quelques incidents au
qu'absolument ans aucun mais l'opération
a été préparée avec beaucoup de soin oui
le chef de béton fait quelle épaisseur
le socle de béton fait environ 25 cm
d'épaisseur il est bien suffisant pour
supporter le poids de la statue qui est
12 tonnes nous allons la protéger des
regards des curieux par des plaques de
tôle qui vont être posées sur le bâti
métalliques comme vous voyez qui entoure
la statue à l'heure actuelle alors la
statue sera remonté ensuite mais comment
sur son même socle non la statue sera
remonté sur un autre sac qui sera plus
moderne
il ira mieux avec le style également
moderne du pont ce socle sera également
plus élevé de façon à remettre la statue
à peu près à son niveau initial
allez vous la nettoyez absolument pas
nous souhaitons ce au contraire
conserver sa patine d'origine
quant à la grande soeur de new york
majestueusement tournés vers l'europe
elle est bien fidèle au poste et n'a pas
l'intention de quitter son socle même
pour fêter ce mois ci ses 80 ans
c'est en effet en octobre 1886 que cette
oeuvre fut inaugurée pour le centième
anniversaire de la guerre de
l'indépendance
et pour concrétiser l'amitié
franco-américaine l'audacieuse sculpteur
français bartholdi déjà auteur du lion
de belfort et du ballon des ternes
venait de réussir une oeuvre gigantesque
dont tous les éléments furent
transportés par bateau dans 214 caisse
la maison de bartholdi à colmar est
maintenant devenu un musée monsieur
d'auge r nous sommes ici dans la maison
natale de bartholdi qui je crois a été
transformée en musée
en effet cette maison contient tout le
mobilier la bibliothèque et la plupart
des maquettes réalisées par cet enfant
d'école marqué le sculpteur bartholdi et
oisy monsieur le modèle définitif de la
statue de liberté de bartholdi la
réaliser et ses petites statuettes qui
se trouve sur la cheminée ce sont les
maquettes les différentes maquettes
qu'il a fait à partir de 1859 la
première est en somme une reproduction
de la maquette du phare de suez auquel
bartoli avait pensé en 1857 et si l'on
veut dire que l'instant si la liberté
est née dans l'esprit de mercredi en
1866 environ sa forme lui a été inspiré
sans aucun doute par la maquette du
phare de suède